модератор мастильного мистецтва ольга
миколаївна багаття на
а доброго дня дуже лаконічно тиша і таня
скаже михайліна буквально напевно ми
досвід візою мама встряла система вся
програма мозаїчного він з тестом
різних уроці показано на кабалівського
циклу сну та душа добрий спеціаліст душа
давно і нас дуже актуально і
натикало вже давно все одно що а і b
для веб чату я за підручником і поему
але нібито проти олаф ж із змінено
це сама мене ти кричиш обмінятися ту
програма треба всі методички см або
інакше ти в 4 хлопець чому б у нас була
небагата коментар на довідки і ті
коментарі і гул і рани були такі
біни зміїним вона bам комусь банів чадів
4вд її творчості б музика ціну так і
шойс надзвичайно моя ніби один не
замути вова не бухтить олена за матового
не а також наша проблема у нас є
кілька кмин заростання скажи про чорти
козочки та дерзі
так я уточню ще ми за пропана вали з
хвилини ми вивчили трохи теорії
на наш погляд ваших теоретичних
моментів як, наприклад, дератизація
інтонації
дівчина на нашу півроку дітям в іншому
класі ви в читера пічну все-таки
інтонація будемо мастильних жанрів ми у
іншому класі ви вивчили симфонічний
природи за вийшов і про параболан падав і
мюзикл у симфонічному з тіста можна
пронести до 5 класу ми вивчили такі
абзац яким вони якутськ вже ми за
смути
за раз я вам скажу не queen звучати
хвали ничку спарений низ музики
слов'янських народів спільної влади
влади українських та російських протяжних
ліричних писати пінгу ласкава багатого
лося ж ніс мобільний впала sev ya
розуміють музичку майстриня ясна можна
аргументу вати та розписати акція все
погляду я а лекція ж українську
неслов'янських народів видно слов'янських
народів і ми вивчили самоціль абзац розум
розділимо обидва один з вид також ми
вивчили дуже багато писання ким же за
100 релізу замість наприклад
священна війна хай завжди будуть сонце
марш із кінофільму в селі бавовняне та
звичайно бігло кицька то намагайся яко вже
цілувала лілія михайлівна
бігло кицька то намагайся і так далі за
текстом добра добра пальник з медом c
для девід та річкових дітей ще там дали
можемо до тих, кому з датою почитати і
пацани читаємо у нашому колективі
викованих людей дякую